-Hey, guys, it is time
for "Tonight Show Hashtags."
Here we go!
-♪ Hashtags ♪
[ Cheers and applause ]
♪ Hashtags ♪
♪♪
-Now, we do this thing
every week
where I send out a hashtag
and ask you guys to respond
to that topic.
So, this week, our hashtag was
"#AddAWordRuinABook."
And I asked you to add one word
to a title of a famous book
and make it way worse.
Within minutes,
it was a trending topic,
so thank you for playing along.
[ Cheers and applause ]
And now, I thought I'd share
some of my favorite responses
from you guys.
This first one is from
@IamTonyTequila.
He says, "James
and The Giant Peach Schnapps."
[ Laughter and applause ]
This is from @RealCatzCatting.
They say, "He Gone, Girl."
[ Laughter ]
[ Cheers and applause ]
♪♪
[ Laughter ]
That's a --
That's a winner right there.
-Come on.
That's a nice one.
-This one's from @mapnelson.
He says, "One Flew Standby
Over the Cuckoo's Nest."
[ Laughter and applause ]
-No?
-This one's from @KaceeBaybee.
She says,
"The Da Vinci Groupon Code."
[ Laughter and applause ]
This one's from @tvwonder.
He says, "The Lion, the Witch,
and the Wardrobe Malfunction."
Well, that's...
[ Laughter and applause ]
This one's from @MyTweetStink.
They say...
"Puss in Ugg Boots."
[ Laughter and applause ]
-Ohh.
-This one's from @Coppertop RN.
She says,
"Children of the Corn Dog."
There you go.
[ Laughter and applause ]
I got it.
This last one's from
@seasonneverends.
He says, "Midnight in the
Olive Garden of Good and Evil."
-Oh!
-There you have it, everybody.
That was
"Tonight Show Hashtags."
To check out more
of our favorites,
go to tonightshow.com/hashtags.